and after one of the most bitterly
fought elections in
modern us history a new session of
congress is formally convening
you're looking at live pictures from
washington d.c
there you have it the first time that
new members of the u.s house and senate
will officially take their seats the
democratic party's nancy pelosi is
expected to remain in charge of the
house of representatives and for now
republican mitch mcconnell still
controls the senate
but that could all change if democrats
win two special elections in georgia on
the fifth please raise your right hand
do you have new members being sworn in
there in those pictures
let's go now for more to washington dc
and our correspondent
carolina chinoi carolina good to see you
what is on the agenda for the new
congress today
happy new year claire well a new
congress as he said convenes
now here in washington dc and this is
117th congress of the united states
the official swearing-in of lawmakers is
taking place the congress
is also coming together for the first
time and so they
will first have to go through all the
organization of the congress
and they will be adopting administrative
resolutions
they should also consent to a date on
which
bills and resolutions may begin to be
introduced
and they of course are going also to
vote
their new speaker the democrat nancy
pelosi as you said
she seeks re-election again but it will
all depend on how many democrats are
able to assist
to the joint session because they all
have to vote in person in washington
on the floor today and this is uh
different than the last
uh bills that could be vote by proxy so
that means
they were allowed to vote from wherever
they were allowing someone
else to cast their ballot in person but
this was due to the pandemic
now they need a new ruling for that and
because of this
the gathering has to be in person so the
vote as well and it will all depend on
how many democrats are going to be in
washington today in order to vote pelosi
we also know that the democrats have
lost some seats in the house but they
still control it
and the senate is not really clear yet
that's right carlene i understand in
addition
to those procedural changes it's also an
unusual situation because it still
remains unclear whether democrats or
republicans will control
the senate what's the story there
that's a very interesting story because
georgia serranova is in two days on the
5th of january
and we're going to see two democrats and
two republicans running for two seats
in the senate and if the democrats if
they do win
all two seats they would control the
senate why
because they would have half of the
seats there and this would give the vice
president that means kamala harris a
democrat the last
word on the votes there we know that a
lot of people have already cast their
mailing ballots similar to
the presidential election and we also
know
that kamala harris is there today in
georgia and donald trump is expected
probably
tomorrow in atlanta and so what does the
outcome of that georgia runoff
mean for president-elect joe biden's
agenda and his ability to get his
policies passed through congress
this is of course very important clear
because this will decide if
uh president biden can pass bills and
reforms
or if he is uh going to be a so-called
elaine duck being blocked
constantly in the upper chamber by the
republican senators
and he would be one of the first
presidents in many years
to become a president without the
majority in this upper chamber
so this will definitely be a very
important election the one in georgia
in two days now carolina we also have a
situation where there are about a dozen
republican lawmakers saying they're
going to object to the formal
certification
of the presidential election that's an
effort to overturn biden's victory
now briefly if you could how big of a
threat is that really to the biden
administration
these are 12 senators there they are
being lead by ted cruz from texas
but they probably are not going to have
a real big
impact on uh electing on seeing
joe biden as a president or not this is
a much more an election to see
a test to see who is supporting donald
trump and who
isn't this is the kind of question that
stays really behind that
all right carolina chimoy in washington
dc thank you so much